[Applause]
[Music]
azerbaijan is their country that you
didn't know existed until you watched
that james bond movie the world is not
enough
nonetheless this country has a lot to
offer yes we are talking again about
natural gas but
believe me there is way more going on
here
[Music]
vito corleone used to say family is an
important matter
and they know this quite well in
azerbaijan in fact the ali family means
everything in their country
[Music]
they control the country's politics and
its economics with an iron fist
nonetheless when it comes to negotiating
they aren't so much into horse heads in
beds but rather caviar yep you heard
that right the allio family can be
corrupt and repressive with their own
citizens but
they know how to treat foreigners like
rock stars five-star hotels caviar
and all kinds of luxuries although if
you're an eu official watching this
video and you're planning on paying a
visit to the
alia family well watch your step because
despite how it looks baku azerbaijan's
capital
is not like las vegas indeed what
happens here we'll stay
on a videotape forever
[Music]
anyway dating on foreigners so much
azerbaijan has managed to become a
member of the council of europe to
participate in the eurovision song
contest and to even play soccer in the
european cup
all of this despite the fact that they
share a border with iran
yes azerbaijan is far from europe but
they're europe's best friend and now you
might wonder why is this country so
attractive
well it's not just the caviar in fact
the caspian sea has many other
interesting things they have
enormous oil reserves and also enormous
gas reserves and you remember who needs
to diversify their gas supplies badly
well of course
that's the european union if you've
watched the previous videos in this
series about russian gas you know that
europe relies heavily
on russia this is why corrupted and
authoritarian as they are in azerbaijan
brussels needs to do business with them
so now i can probably guess what you're
thinking putin is not going to be happy
with this
right at the end of the day russia wants
europe to depend on their gas
so anytime they look for other providers
that's bad news for the kremlin but
actually the reality is
the opposite's true as we said the ali
family has turned diplomacy into an art
form
and they know how to befriend everyone
including putin
so the question now becomes why is baku
so
important to moscow how can azerbaijan
be europe and putin's friends
at the same time and well what does
ukraine have to do with any of this
well today we're going to answer all of
these questions but before we do
let's take a look back at the history
javier diplomacy may 2014 the uruguayan
soccer player diego godin scores the
goal that allows atletico madrid to win
the european soccer league now if you're
american this probably doesn't mean very
much to you but outside of america
soccer's a bit of a big deal so
millions of viewers from all over the
world were watching soccer on tv
with a t-shirt that reads azerbaijan
land of fire
this was the case between the years of
2012 to 2015. so now you might be
wondering
why did azerbaijan spend 24 million
euros to sponsor a
soccer team in spain maybe they were
trying to promote tourism but have you
ever heard anyone say oh yes i'm going
to azerbaijan this holiday season it's
going to be lovely
no me neither the answer it has nothing
to do with tourism
in 2009 as you might know europeans
spent several days without gas because
there were gas wars between russia
and ukraine that was the moment when the
european union had started looking for
alternative gas suppliers
at the same time azerbaijan was enjoying
a gas
boom
[Music]
in 2006 the chardonnay's gas field began
production
and this was a big gas field it was so
big that it could help europe
reduce their russian dependency by 10 in
other words europe was desperately
looking for suppliers and azerbaijan was
desperately looking for buyers love was
in the air
[Music]
but as you know love it needs a spark it
needs a little passion
this is where the so-called caviar
diplomacy comes in
you see nobody likes to do business with
a dictatorship but
in baku they have money to buy just
about everything now normally no one's
willing to sponsor the european games
because they're kind of like the
olympics but they're a lot smaller and
they make no financial sense but
this wasn't a problem because azerbaijan
was happy to pay with their oil money
[Music]
valencia a spanish city no longer
possible to host formula one there no
problem
azerbaijan pays with their oil money
maybe need sponsors for the european cup
again no problem azerbaijan's got that
old money and they're gonna pick up the
bill no matter if we're talking about
the brand
azerbaijan land of fire or soca which is
azerbaijan's oil company
the ali family money is everywhere and
this
explains news like this
[Music]
euro 2020 get ready for games from
bilbao
to baku and more minnows yes you heard
that right the next euro cup will be
played in 11 countries and that
includes azerbaijan despite not being
european
and not really having a strong tradition
of soccer with these kinds of events
azerbaijan has a great chance to improve
their image and body political goodwill
thanks to this nobody has any problem
with building all of the pipelines they
want
this is how we have the south caucasus
pipeline which connects the caspian sea
with turkey and crosses
georgia this one has been in operation
since 2006 and
looks like this
yes yes i know the kind of looks weird
on the map right it looks like they were
drunk when they were designing it the
reason why it's not a straight line is
because azerbaijan doesn't want to cross
armenia the relationship between armenia
and azerbaijan is even worse than the
relationship between russia
and ukraine this is why they'd rather
cross
georgia and this is why russia who is
more pro-armenian
is not a good friend of the ali family
but that's something we're going to talk
about later after
this pipeline came the tan app which
goes all the way down to greece the tan
app started operation this year 2018
and the final project is the so-called
tap which is expected to go all the way
to italy now the big question is what
does putin think about all of this well
in the beginning he was far from happy
in fact he tried to stop azir
gas from arriving in italy at any cost
how did he do this well essentially he
called up his italian friends
remember from a previous video how
gerhardt schroeder is putin's man in
berlin well
in rome he's got bepe grillo the leader
of the five stars movement which is a
populist party
[Music]
watch out for connections between russia
and the five stars movement and this is
why beppe
grillo used to say things like this
wanna make this pipe in puglia rather
than any other place
we will bring the army if necessary
let's pause that right there this
declaration is from 2014 but we're
making
this video in 2018. four years is a
pretty long time so let's fast forward
and see what's happening
everything remains at home every dynasty
has a godfather
and this is the story of haidar alive he
started his career as a kgb spy for 25
years he
was sort of the james bond of baku then
in 1969 soviet
general secretary leonid brezhnev named
him the leader of the soviet republic
of azerbaijan his political career it
soared until the 1980s when he had
problems with
later general secretary mikhail
gorbachev
then in 1991 azerbaijan gained
independence in two years haidar aliev
became the president with
pay attention here 98.8
of the vote yes this is the azerbaijan
style of democracy
nonetheless hadar he was a man of
compromise he used to be a good
communist but he easily adapted to the
capitalistic framework
in less than a year he signed the
so-called contract of the century
bp exxon chevron and the norwegian stat
oil
they all wanted to have their share of
azerbaijan's gas
and oil and i leave he was happy to give
it to them in exchange for a juicy
80 percent of the profits in fact
remember that james bond movie i
mentioned earlier the world is not
enough well that movie opened with a
scene where piers brosnan is driving a
car through oil rigs in their country
and as a side tip by the way james bond
is an amazing geopolitical compass
anytime they choose a location for
shooting it's because that country is
very interested in appearing in a movie
and if they're interested it's usually
for a reason alright so let's get back
to today's movie azerbaijan's economy
skyrocketed they had oil they had gas
and they had caviar the country grew and
so
did its corruption everything remains in
the family business
and as vito corleone used to say a man
who doesn't spend time with his family
can never be a real man so upon the
death of the godfather hadar alive in
his son ilham inherited the business
[Music]
this time he won the elections with 75
percent of the vote
and yes as you know by now azerbaijan's
style of democracy is rather amusing
if you don't believe me just look at
this news
oops azerbaijan released election
results before voting had even started
in fact ilhan
alive doesn't even waste time pretending
not to be corrupt he changed the
constitution so that he can run for
elections as many times as he wants the
vice president of the country that's
also
his wife by the way and he also changed
the law that specified the age required
to run for elections before you had to
be older than 35 to run for president
but his son is only 21 and you never
know
and of course anybody who speaks against
the ali family they end up in jail
meanwhile they're getting richer and
richer every year remember the panama
papers well one of the biggest clients
of mossack fonseca was the alives
so well what do you do when you have as
much money as you want
well you use it to make friends
corruption inquiry at council of europe
over azerbaijan
all right so we slam and ask the big
question though how did they manage to
befriend putin well
we're going to tell you right now
[Music]
real politic michael corleone used to
say keep your friends close but your
enemies closer if you remember vladimir
putin has
two goals on his agenda
[Music]
one is to sell gas to europe and the
other is to bypass ukraine
on the gas transit after the gas wars
the nordstrom 1 and nordstrom 2 were
built these pipelines connect directly
russia and germany through the baltic
sea but this isn't enough
if they want to isolate ukraine forever
they need more
pipes in the south and that is harder
than it looks
look what happened when they tried the
first time
suspends south stream gas pipeline
project unlike azerbaijan putin isn't so
brilliant when it comes to diplomacy the
crimea invasion cost him a lot of
economic sanctions and made europe stop
the pipeline that the kremlin wanted to
build
so putin had to look for a better
strategy and
with this in mind the azerbaijan pipe it
didn't look so bad anymore you see if
europe is investing in having a pipe in
the south to get gas from azerbaijan
russia can also send their gas through
it and this this
is how the turk stream was born turk
stream is another pipe that goes from
russia
to turkey but once it gets to turkey you
can also connect it with the other pipe
that goes to italy just have a look at
this map
in other words russia's play goes as
follows they bring the gas to turkey
from there it goes to italy so that the
pipe that was originally designed to be
for azerbaijan's gas
will carry russian gas as well in other
words the ali family
is no longer a threat to putin but
actually an opportunity and things have
changed in russia and they've changed in
literally too
remember how that five stars movement
was completely against the tap pipeline
well now the five-star movement is one
of the
ruling parties in italy and well guess
what they say now
[Music]
tap is not strategic but it is shielded
meanwhile there are two world leaders
that have become really good friends
[Music]
this looks like the ending to a
hollywood movie the european union is
happy because
now they can diversify their gas supply
azerbaijan is happy too because
now they're going to become enormously
rich russia is happy as well because
they can bypass ukraine once and for all
yes everybody seems to be happy except
for ukraine
they most likely have a very very dark
future
so now i have a question for you do you
think europe will let putin achieve his
goals with ukraine do you think the ali
family will keep running the country as
a family business
what do you think will happen with
ukraine please leave your answer in the
comment section below we'd love to hear
from you also don't forget to visit
reconsider media.com the podcast that
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine
if you like this video don't forget that
we publish brand new videos every week
so subscribe and hit that bell button
and you won't miss any posts
and as always i'll see you next time
[Music]